I could be giving birth to my third child in four weeks.
Just so crazy to think about.
I never thought I'd be 22
with three kids,
three and under,
but it's been a very wild ride that I'm so excited for.
So today, let's spend a realistic morning together.
I've been getting the worst sleep,
so I kind of wake up whenever my kids wake up.
So they just hung out with me while I
put down all of my to DOS,
did my scriptures,
and journaled a little bit.
Lately I'm obsessed with robus tea again,
but it has to be with milk and sugar.
There's no other way I'll drink it.
And then I made some pancakes this morning.
Pancakes seem like a very simple thing to do,
but they have not always been my strong soup. But now
I figured out a recipe that actually works really well.
So I made the kids some,
and I had lucky flip them,
which didn't go that great.
Cut up some strawberries.
They always have theirs with some apple sauce,
and lucky has his with maple syrup
and a bunch of strawberries on top.
Once everyone had their breakfast,
I made mine.
I couldn't decide,
so I had some bagel and cream cheese,
and then also some of the pancakes
with some leftover peach puree.
This is usually the time where I respond to emails
and texts and other things that need to be done
in order for lucky
And I to both get work done during the day.
He takes the mornings
and I take the afternoons.
So he clocked out
and I was on kids duty.
So I just did all the breakfast cleanup
since he does the evening cleanup.
I also stained my cutting board,
and the trick that always helps is hot water,
so I made sure to do that.
And then I got the babies dressed
and all ready for the day
before it was finally my turn to get ready.
My skin has been struggling a little bit lately.
It's been really dry,
and I think my eczema is kind of flaring up a little,
but it's not bad at all,
so I'm not even gonna worry about it.
I'm trying to make my hair last a
few more days before I have to wash it,
so I've just been doing half up,
half down hairstyles.
Also, you guys have been asking me for my lip combo.
She's almost the same in every video.
It's the MAC lip liner and Cork,
and then I put the Benedint lip stain in the middle,
top it with a clear gloss.
I also bought some baby stuff the other day
as we're slowly starting to get ready,
and I forgot how tiny their little diapers are.
Pretty much the size of my hand.
I also unbox
some of the packages that came over the last few days.
It was so sweet.
The Tory Burge team sent Me,
the look I wore to their show,
which I can't wait to wear.
And at this point,
I realised that we were
running late to my midwife appointment,
so I made myself a quick smoothie
while lucky got the kids ready and loaded in the car.
My last babies have been home births,
and I've had a midwife with all of them,
so I knew that with this one,
I wanted to do the exact same thing.
Had the most amazing experiences using midwives
and just giving birth at home.
Rumble and slim
love listening to the baby's heartbeat,
and it makes it all feel so real.